sometimes when you're small and you're
coming up you're trying to make your
marriage work you're trying to raise
kids you're trying to pay the bills
you're trying to hire people you're
trying to expand you're trying to go and
grow your business get better read books
listen to audio take courses attend
events fill up the gas tank change the
all this stuff that you have in your
life that you're dealing with
sometimes you don't have time to sit
here and think about other things and
then Market that you have zero control
over happens that's not on you how does
a person who has zero influence over the
market okay maybe they have control over
20 people's votes to change them or
certain things how does a person who has
no control over politics at this phase
of their lives no control over the
market at this phase of their life no
control over interest rates at this
phase of their life how do they properly
make the Right Moves to still be
effective where the Market's going to go
good battle rugby thank you I said this
the last night to that group last night
is the purpose of a leader is not to be
the leader
the purpose of the leader is to take
what
a great elect Patrick does
and pass that lesson on
so your job I congratulate you for being
here you could be a lot of other places
today
well I think your most important job is
to take what Patrick is teaching
and pass it on to your people outside
this country
or your home
we need leaders right ladies and
gentlemen right now and Patrick is one
of the best as I said when I met him so
many years ago
this big bus pulls up and I said who is
this guy
but the mama looked in his eyes I knew
who he was
because his core values are solid
I said last night it's our core values
then you have the uh culture and I'll
say that's organization
so in the U.S army when I found out he
was 82nd Airborne
I knew who he was
because the Army is a big organization
the culture is
um 82nd Airborne
but the core values of what drive him
and we can duplicate his values
we win
okay thank you
stock markets when they crash go down in
three phases boom boom boom
phase one was was bounced it was called
a bear Market rally
this paper is going down I hope because
I'm going to get richer
the thing right now is if you're afraid
it's because you got bad advice at your
head
you're operating on bad information from
your mommy your daddy your college
professor your school teachers whatever
it is
I get sexually stimulated thinking about
a crash
yeah because I'll say it again the
tougher it is the smarter you've got to
be that's why I honor you for being here
this is a great leader passes word on I
did the same thing in my cash flow board
game in my books I pass on what I was
taught
that's how you serve other people
if you understand that
and then it's your skill set I'll tell
you a quick story
when I came back from Vietnam I said I
said to my Rich Dad I said I want to be
an entrepreneur like you he says why God
take sales lessons two classes to take
real estate courses which I did and yet
a lot of sell
I said I don't want to know how to sell
because my poor dad always says sells
another scum
that was my poor death that's why he's a
PhD poor helpless desperate you know he
couldn't
oh he was a son he was a great father
but he was poor man
so finally I kept arguing with my Rich
Dad I said I don't want to learn how to
sell and finally rich dad said to me
says you know him 25 26 years old Prime
of life
you know Marine all this stuff he says
how's your sex life Robert
non-existent he says because you can't
[ __ ] sell
[Music]